- Hi, I'm Patti Harrison.
- Huge bitch, and
I'm Joel Kim Booster.
(bleeps)
- And you're watching Unsend,
where we celebrate the best
and the worst of the web,
but mostly the worst.
(upbeat electronic
industrial music)
(audience cheers)
(paper crunches)
- Listen, it's time to
tackle a hard-hitting issue
that rubs each and every
one of us the wrong way.
I'm not talking about ISIS,
I'm talking about Instagram ads.
- Ugh, the worst!
Yay, ISIS.
(dramatic music)
(glass breaking)
- Look, we're going
to Instagram to gawk
at shapely male bodies,
and to find out what
our ex, Alex is doing.
Did he book that Broadway show?
I'm dying to know,
he will update me.
- Right, but these
ads are coming at us
every other scroll down,
and it's pissing my
ass off, you bitch!
- Language.
If you're gonna invade our
feed, at least be better
than this yotpo ad.
Look at this disaster, ugh!
(both exclaiming in disgust)
- This fellow looks like he
tried to pledge a fraternity
but lost his way
during Hell Week.
- Ugh.
- I'm sorry, yotpo, but I'm
reading and re-reading this ad,
and I still don't know-po
what it is you're selling.
- Hmm, good.
Yeah, before you boast
about your 5,000 reviews,
maybe let us in on who you are.
- We don't know Jake Kassan,
We don't know MVMT Watches,
and we don't know you.
- Now let's move on to
the most nefarious evil
in this rat king of evil:
attractive females peddling tea.
Let's examine FitTea in ads.
- (raspy voice)
Baby, I love butts!
- Uh-uh.
- (raspy voice) This one
really takes the cake,
pun intended, like an ass.
An ass made of cake.
There's no better sales
person than a big booty Judy.
These girls let their
asses do the talking
and spoiler alert:
(raspy voice) I'm listening
with my little pud out.
(laughs)
- I had an eating
disorder for six years.
(paper crunching)
(air whistling)
- We're here with the
effortlessly cool Jimmy O. Yang.
You can find him on all
his social media handles
@FunnyAsianDude, and he
is a funny Asian dude,
but was he always
a funny Asian dude?
I guess we're about to find out
when we dive into your
old Instagram posts
in a little segment
we like to call
Defend or Delete.
(horn blares)
- [Patti] We have
this first post here.
- "Got my sag card in the
mail today, now waiting
"for my v card to arrive."
- "Hashtag acting, hashtag sag."
- Wow.
- Yo, okay, the post, I got
no problem with the post,
but the hashtag is sad as ****.
- I feel that.
- Like, this is, I hate
people when they do #setlife,
#acting is so whack.
- You think a lot of people
are searching #acting,
just perusing?
- Yeah, when they're looking
for actors.
- Well, no, casting
directors, do.
- Yeah, that's
what they told me.
- Um, I saw, this is crazy,
I saw Steven Spielberg
on a laptop at a coffee
shop, and I like kind of
creeped behind him,
and I was like:
Whoa, what's he looking at?
He was on Twitter and
Instagram at the same time,
just looking at
#actor, #setlife, #sag,
and was casting.
- That's how he found me.
- From these hashtags.
- [Jimmy] Yeah.
- Please don't, no.
- See go like this.
- I don't wanna be involved.
- I wanna do a #setlife, guys.
(Joel sighs)
(camera clicks)
- Huh, see, that's, I
missed that, hang on.
- I just have to get my
genitals out for it get likes.
(Patti grunts)
(camera clicks)
- Good, see?
You're gonna, we're gonna
get so many followers
from the #setlife.
- Next, "I just joined
the #Darkside" (laughs).
- Wow.
Wait, this is on my Instagram?
- Um, yeah, that's you.
- Oh, ****.
- Oh my god, Jimmy!
You really threw down and
you bought an iPad, whoa!
- On February 5th, 2013,
Jimmy O. Yang bought an iPad.
- Ooh, it's dark!
- You gotta (sighs)
- Oh, oh my god!
- You gotta understand
how poor I was
when it was 2013.
- Oh!
- And this was like a
milestone in my life.
- Ooh, you know what,
some people are good,
and some people are bad
to the ******* bone,
and they don't have keyboards.
- 2013.
You got an iPad.
You joined SAG.
- Whoa, that was a big
year for you, Jimmy.
- That was a good
- It was, it was, it
was, it was a good year.
- Are you gonna
defend or delete this?
- I feel like it's so bad,
and now people will
see it on the show,
I don't know if anybody
watches the show,
but if they do see
it on the show,
then I'm gonna look like an
idiot deleting this like:
Oh, I'm ashamed of it, so I
might as well just live with it,
and like be proud of it.
- Yeah.
(bell dings)
- You guys at home, I
want you to find this post
on Instagram, and like
it, and tell Jimmy
you're with him on the
dark side, honey, okay.
Thank you so much, Jimmy,
for coming in today.
This was so much fun, we've
learned a lot about you,
and your stupid little brain.
- I really thought there were
some good photos in there,
and I think you're
a really cool guy,
and I think there's
a lot of cool things
that you are gonna
show us in the future.
- I can't wait to see
what you do, you idiot.
(happy upbeat music)
- I love each and every
one of you so much.
I know that this time is
a hard time to live in.
- I wanna feel what
your insides feel like.
- But just keep going.
Wake up every day, say:
I'm gonna do something
that makes me happy, even
if it's one little act
of kindness to yourself.
- I'm just gonna get in there
Do that for me.
- and feel your guts.
If you do that
- I'm gonna feel all around
for anyone else,
- inside your guts
do it for me.
- and your body and I'm gonna
I grew up a Christian,
- I'm gonna be like a parasite
and even though I don't
- growing deeper and deeper
necessarily identify
- and bigger and bigger
as a Christian any more,
- inside your body
I think that spirituality
- and that's... (laughs)
is important and I
hope you do, too.
Thanks for watching Unsend.
Joel, don't come in that.
(heavy hip-hop music)